[Music]
a rugby player continues to suffer from
chronic infections to his leg for more
than a decade oh
what color is it good question
how'd you know to ask about the color
jumbo size what's what color do you
think because it's infected is that a
staph infection
like what
is what is called cellulitis hey where
do you do jumbo nice it looks like a
flaming hot cheeto oh it tastes like it
too
as well
how do you think that happened he's just
a rugby player through a cut and then
just like dirt
through not showering and then tossing
and turning with other sweaty men and
then just thinking it's not a big deal
and then over time you're like oh it's
just a spider bite and then you just you
know and it gets infected probably in
this particular case spiders because
it's
australia it's poop an opponent during a
game
had some dog [ __ ] on his shoe wow that
is poop and then pike on the shoe
got into his leg
and he intravenously uh took a little
bit of poopoo
are we sure it was the spike and not
they took the soccer ball and as soon as
they got there they bounced it
i was thinking about that and it made me
feel so remorseful
oh no you get a cut on your forehead and
you think about where soccer plays i
used to i used to do the old kaka ball
trick which um now i know it could have
repercussions yeah it could actually
have serious helpers i would take
sporting goods and just smudge him in
the poop toss him to the next guy and uh
never thought he'd have an open wound
never thought he'd have a 10 year
infection but yeah it's crazy that it's
recurring like the like a treatment of
antibiotics didn't get rid of it you
can't keep it down in 10 years it'll
come back every few years whoa
it's because it's a colony it's a living
organism you know it keeps coming back
to barnacle basically so what do they
gotta do is rip it off just get rid of
the leg
really no
if you guys had a leg right that was
getting affected every few years would
you guys rather deal with it or just
amputate it i would rather deal with it
i'd rather deal with
it until it's as small as possible and
cut out that chunk
i'm an optimist i would try to find a
cure
i would try to heal like find a way and
then if it doesn't then you just crawl
up your leg we'll see how many years
you're knocking this my friend yeah
it could infect your bloodstream and
then you die responds to an optimist
thank you
just break him down
because you it could affect your
bloodstream and then you die so it's
either you lose a leg or you die yeah
yeah see that's what he's an optimist
though so who gives a [ __ ]
but i won't die right well yeah i mean
i think you will as a pessimist
or a realist you won't die a pessimist's
death what's the in-between an optimus
and a pessimist regular um
it's like pick a team already dude
commit commit come on you like kind of
believe there's a god but you don't know
which one to commit to so so this guy
after experiencing this and having to go
through it now he's kind of like an
advocate of trying to keep his
neighborhood clean he's trying to you
know he's picking up dog [ __ ] well he's
trying to encourage um you know the just
the general populace to do that to me to
use the basketball for their dogs
because pick up the belt something like
this could happen that's crazy but i
mean
come on dude like what are the odds
can you imagine just saying that to what
dude i mean i see what you're doing but
come on dude come on wait so there's
you're gonna die this hill there was dog
[ __ ] on the rugby field yeah
and then another player stepped in it
and then during their little you know
scuffles yeah duffel did it on purpose
man
you think so he might have weighed those
pools are kind of dirty
but how did he know it was that he
stepped in dog did they like use like
did the little poo poo check
so they went something smells oh
that's a dog [ __ ] let's be real somebody
had an emotional support animal which is
a big problem right now because
everybody got a [ __ ] emotional
support whatever
and then that dog takes a [ __ ] and then
that person doesn't clean it up and then
this person's like stuck for life with
this [ __ ] yeah i'm not a big fan of
people not picking up their dog [ __ ] i
feel like it's really rude and if you
have a dog
you need to pick up your dog dude i was
at a [ __ ]
joanne's fabrics
do i want to be there of course nobody
wants to be there i'm held hostage
might as well have a [ __ ] gun might
as well have an israeli ex-military guy
with a gun to my [ __ ] head the whole
time okay but guess what my wife wants
to go to joanne's fabrics so i'm there
what do i see chick has a [ __ ]
emotional support dog to go to joann's
fabrics
what do you need it for
you you just did what you because she
gets anxiety attacks when she looks at
like satin or some [ __ ] the thread
counts are overwhelming for her should i
can't buy crocheting material without
breaking down
get the [ __ ] out of joanne's fabrics
they go to amazon.com or whatever
shop
so the dog never did anything i think
you say [ __ ] on the ground or something
nah i was fine it just existed it just
pissed me off because i'm like why are
you so special everybody oh everybody
doesn't need a little hug every now and
then from the animal give me a break
what do you think about um emotional
support animals
like when they try to bring them into
like korean barbecue restaurants
i think it's it's a it's conflict of
interest as long as they don't [ __ ] cuz
that's happened where i see them
fighting like arguing with the with the
host and being like you guys legally
have to let me in they got this giant
dog at a korean barbecue where it's
already going
like yeah or not yeah we're making
noises that's illegal but that's torture
for that poor animal that animal wants
to eat too yeah just [ __ ] food all
over the place everywhere not his height
yeah
how is that not a conflict of interest
where the dog is like i got i want to
eat something oh i gotta eat dog food
though that's [ __ ] i feel like they
try to do that to feed the dog cheap so
then they have this big [ __ ] dog
they're like what are we gonna do let's
just we're gonna eat dinner anyway let's
go to korean barbecue and start throwing
some [ __ ] meat while we eat oops
another cowbee
yeah no i mean they didn't let them in
ultimately and those people were really
pissed but i mean of course i feel like
asian establishments they don't give a
[ __ ] yeah
because like we try to do that at a dim
sum uh my friend had his dog with them
and i was like
[ __ ] just say it's emotional support
they won't discriminate and then we walk
in they're like excuse me
you have a paper for that dog
and then i'm like it's emotional support
not supposed to ask no sorry get out
here it's it's supposed to be service
animal not yeah emotions there's two
different things because one person can
have a disability where they need the
animal but then this is like
is it a disability so like when you go
to shabuya and
town
there's a sign that says by ada
regulations your uh your dog must be
disability support not emotional um so
that's the distinction
yeah i mean i guess they they have i
mean they can be cool and say like yeah
emotional support dogs welcome they can
be cool and do that but they don't
actually have to answer what's gonna
happen when a dog shits in the
restaurant though and they put it in
their bowl
what if they were blind and the dog is
supposed to be helping them and the dog
shits how did the blind person know that
you better know how to pick it up
i never thought of that dude yeah i was
just thinking about that
i don't look down on blind people enough
like you probably do to think that they
can't do it of course i think they can
probably do it better than i can
or look at that
that's kind of hot they can't get the
plastic bag out they could smell where
it is oh no can think they can't smell
it by the way at korean bbq you can't
you can't smell it but not now that you
pick it up where do you put it now i
can't say it because they're blind they
don't know what they're saying he
doesn't know it they don't even know
what it is you can't see it right yeah
no i said the smell was stronger because
they can't see well now you're saying
this yeah that's all you said off camera
dude
this is what i think i think that um i
think that most esa's are obviously
they're not really trained to be they're
just their dog but if you're a blind
person and you come in with a trained
dog i think there's some kind of
training the dog has
not immediately [ __ ] when it needs to
probably go back outside or something
support dogs they're they're
dude they're like [ __ ] police canines
man they'll pick up their own [ __ ] and
bag it
it's true
it speaks korean it's like more bulgogi
i got a buddy who has like a 350 000
german shepherd oh yeah where like they
put it through like all the training and
all the [ __ ] and all the stuff that's
expensive and it's like a bomb squad dog
or x-bomb squad dog that like you can do
like personal defense with and [ __ ] yeah
it's [ __ ] tight as a [ __ ] crypto
whale but yeah but that's the point is
that he wants to have a security system
like and a dog at the same time so you
get to pet and love it but it will bite
the [ __ ] out of somebody that's trying
to steal your crypto keys but but for
like 24 months it was like somebody
else's dog while they were being raised
and then like there's a day that comes
where like a couple days where this
person who like this dog like loved the
most
trains uh the dog to like you more
and that was a [ __ ] weird thing
that must be so heartbreaking so you
raise it yeah and then you send them to
doggy boot camp yep and then when he
comes back it's in doggy boot camp
during the puppy face yeah yeah they
teach them all the commands and
everything there but then the trade-off
is where the the important thing happens
but this dog is actually trained to
treat you
by command
to be their new master and then they
will treat you the way that they treat
the person that they were with like two
years and it's usually non-english
commands too yes no it's it's like
[ __ ] a german order yes so that like
like uh
robbers or perpetrators can't say like
sit or whatever like they'll only
respond to that language it's german
yeah but what if you're in germany
yeah but this dog can smell bomb [ __ ]
like like it can yeah you can find gun
powder like it's crazy that's a badass
[ __ ] dog it's 350 grand yeah holy
[ __ ] that's a lot
that that that with that kind of money
that [ __ ] that dog better defuse a bomb
i jump in front of a bullet for you too
with that kind of like pull out a gun i
might go
who needs a body guard when you got a
doggy guard so you could tell your dog
to like attack people yeah yeah if he
uses a certain command it will attack
anything he wants do you know the
command uh he told me but i don't
remember because it's german at night i
failed spanish so many times i'll never
remember german
what if they're playing wolfenstein and
then the dog starts doing [ __ ] because
they hear the german command oh my i
never thought of it
[Music]
you